[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جمال حاجه ما بتحسش ما عندهاش اي مشاعر
يا ترى ايه اللي خلاني يا جماعه
او الاله بحاجه كلها مشاعر حاجه حيه
ميكس غريب لما تفكر فيه شويه تحس ان هو ما
لوش معنى شويه طيب ليه عملت ده وايه موضوع
موضوع الثوم بتاعي نفسه هنعرف المغزى او
الحدث
قبل ما اقول يعني ايه موشن ماشين وانا ليه
اتكلمت عنها
العنوان هاعمل مقارنه بسيطه
تقريبا 90% منكم هيحس نفسه في شخصيا مش
شخصيتين دول طيب انا ليه هعمل مقارنه دي
المق
ارنه دي شويه يا ترى لو كان من حقي ان انا
اختار اكون شخصيه غير شخصيتين هختار اكون
انهي واحده
طيب
مجموعه من الصور الصور دي الناس اغلبكم
تعرفوها بالفعل انكم عندها انطباع بسيط
شويه عارفينها وعارفين هي مين بالظبط طيب
عايزه اعرف يا ترى ايه الصفه اللي بتجمعها
بكل الشخصيات دي ايه الحاجه اللي بينهم
جوكر
الشخصي
ات دي قاعد معنا دلوقتي واول سؤال هساله
يا ترى انت عارف ان انت شخصيه شريره عارف
الناس كلها بتقول عليك وحشه تقريبا 50% من
الحالات هيقول لك لا انا مش شايف ان انا
غلطان وممكن يديك مورات انت شخصيا
ايه المشكله بيبقى عنده اقناع كامل هو زي
الفل انا
حد كويس جدا
المشكله الاساسيه يعني مفكرو شويه كده
المشكله ممكن تكون فين
اصلا هو عنده مشكله لما انا مش عارف انا
وحش ما حد
ش اغلب الشخص
يات اللي حواليها شبهها شويه يعني
بيدعموها نفس افكارهم ونفس يعني نفس حوار
الشر ده هم برده كلهم مش مدركين ما حدش
نبهني يمكن لو حد نبههم قبل كده ان انت
ممكن تكون عندك مشكله كان خد بالك
طيب دول شمسيه 50
انا خايف الناس بعد كده في كل مشكله
تغلطني انت على طول غلط التفكير غلط اه
شايف ان
لا انا حتى لو غلطان مش هعتذر ما عندوش
ازمه احساس بالذنب ولا احساس بالماسونيه
شمعته وهو فاضيه بس شمعت الناس اللي قدامي
مليانه اخطاء عندهم نرجسيه مؤذيه جدا جدا
رغم كل ما
الاشخاص الا انه مش بيكونوا ظاهرين فيها
قوي طب ليه انتم عارفين ان هم بيكون اكثر
اشخاص نجاحا عموما بيكونوا اكثر انتاجيه
جدا عن غيرهم لانهم مش عايزين اصلا تغلطوا
يعني مش هيدوك اساسا انك تقول لهم
مجهود خرافي عشان يطلع احسن كده
طيب ممكن يا ترى يكون
اول حاجه هنا الابراج يعني مشكله مبدئيا
تعرف ان في مشكله وبعدين
تاني حاجه انك تعرف انك انسان ضعيف ممكن
تتغير مش متاني ومش كامل ابدا ربنا ما
خلقناش خالص مثاليين او كبار على الخطا
بالعكس الاجهزه اللي في ايدينا
دي كلها يوم اجابه اي
دك
الابديت بتاع بكره نزل ما فيهوش مشكله بس
نسي البطاريه اليوم اللي بعده نسيوا الكفر
لو انت مقتنع
النهارده واللي عاجبه عاجبه واللي مش
عاجبه يمشي انت ظالم منك ان انت واقف في
مكانك لكن انت لا الحقيقه بترجع لورا قدام
ابدا
النهارده ان انا عندي مشكله كمان خمس
دقائق اخترت ان انا اتغير اخترت ان انا
اغير الصفه دي
مفيش اي حد له حق انه يلومني ان انت مثلا
كنت بتعملي كذا امبارح بالعكس الانسان
يتغير
حتى مسؤول عن نفسك وعن اخطار قررت اتغير
فدي نقطه حلوه جدا
طيب
يا ترى الاحسان بالظبط حاجه كويسه
حاجه صحيه وطبيعيه جدا ليه عشان ضمير
خايفه الجهاز انذار انت متربي على مبادئ
ومتربي على حدود معينه فجاه كسرت حد من
الحدود دي عملت حاجه غلط عن اللي انت
تحبيك عليها
انت في حاجه في حاجه غلط حصلت عارفين اللي
هو بتغلط خدت بالك ان انت غلطت بت
دق حاجه طبعا
هو اللي بيصحيه لما تغلط هو اللي بيصحيك
لما تعمل حاجه غلط
طيب
لما بيزيد
لما بيطلع وحش ينقلب لاداه لتعذيب النفس
البشريه ذاتي انا بحس بالذنب على كل حاجه
في حياتي
انا شايف ان انا استاهل تخيل حصلت حاجه
حلوه انا اكيد المره
لو حصلت حاجه انا اصلا اقل حاجه تحصل
خالص
مش حابه
خالص احساسي بالذنب
غلط خليتني
خالص بقى على الكتف ان انا مش مدركه ان طب
ليه انا
بيرتبط كمان باللي انت
جامد اوف
كل الامور اللي في حياتك تخيل حد من
اصحابك يكون بيهزر معاك
بتفكر
فيها ايه ممكن ما تنامش من الاكتئاب ده
حقيقي دي بالظبط الشخصيه شخص بيلوم نفسه
على كل حاجه على قد ما انت تشوفه ضحيه بس
هو مش ضحيه ابدا لان هو عايز ان هو بياذ
نفسه ومع ذلك مش بياخد خطوه ابدا تجاه
نفسه
طيب
دلوقتي بقى ما قلت لكم صفات الشخصيتين يا
ترى لو هتختاري طبعا انا عارفه انت ممكن
تكون شخصيتين دول هتختاري هتكونوا تحبوا
تكون
الحقيقه الشخصيتين مش حاجه ليه
الشخصيتين
عندهم اكسترا واحد ما بيحسش خالص واحد
عنده اكسترا في المشاعر
فالوسطين
ان انا حد بيتقور الامور يعني انا ممكن
اشوف مشكله بسيطه
بتهدد مستقبلي انا مكبر المواضيع فعلا
ممكن اشوف طبعا هو
حاجه
بطيئه ما تضحك
حاولت ان انا الاقي الموضوع تقريبا
25 جنيه استخلصت فيهم الموضوع بتاع
النهارده
طيب ليه انا قلت ماشيين يا ترى
ماشي مش المقصود بها جمال لا
اله
الا كنترول بروجرام
يعني اقول لك اه حتى لو هتمشي من شعرك
الكلام تحسه ان هو صعب جدا لما تكون منظم
حتى في مشاعرك بتلاقي حياتك كلها عموما
طيب انا جمعته استفز ان انا قريتها من 25
كتاب دول خمس
اول حاجه او اول خطوه تاخدها اتجاه نفسك
عشان تحل عموما المشكله اللي بتلاقيها في
عشوائيه مشاعرك اكسبت يعني ايه
بتغلط لما تغلط ينفع تعتذر انت مش كامل
ولا مثالي ينفع تقول اه انا اسف تقابل
فعلا ممكن تغلط وساعتها هتتعامل مع نفسك
بحنيه شويه بلاش قصره يعني الاستاذ الفاشل
اللي هتلاقيه مثلا كل مره الطالب بتاعه
يغلط كل مره يعملكه وكل مره
بس الحقيقه انه الفكره
في مره يا عمتو طبعا دي اخر حاجه استماره
الاولى هينصحك المره الثانيه هيعدل عليه
هيساعده
تخيل نفسك انت بتعملها ازاي كل مره بتعمل
حاجه غلط بتقدر تلوم نفسك اللي هو مش
طبيعي طب ليه انت انسان فعلا مش كامل اصلا
انت عباره عن غلط غلطات كثيره متكرره بس
انت بتحاول تصلحها طيب دي اول ثاني
افهم مشاعرك بمعنى ايه كلمه اكتئاب بتتردد
على امثالنا كلنا دلوقتي انا على طول
مكتئب يا جماعه في فرق ما بين الزعل
والاكتئاب يعني لحظه كده نفهم ان الزعل
حاجه والاكتئاب حاجه الاكتئاب ده مرض
الناس بتتعالج منه بادويه
ظهر حاجه بسيطه ليه احنا كل
لا انا مكتئبه ليه كل ما تقول خفت شويه
مثلا
من الامتحان انا جاي
لا هو مش كل شويه
يدخل ليه الادب بيتحول لفجاعه انك مش قادر
تتعامل معاه انتم عارفين القلق ساعتها
بتعمل حاجات في حياتك زي مثلا انك تروح
امتحان
انتم عارفين في ناس كثير لما بتفرح بتفضل
سنين واقفه في مكانها مش عارفه تاخد خطوه
وعايشه على الانجازات اللي فاتت
لازم نفهم مشاعرنا وتفرق ما بينها خذ كده
افهمه ان انا دلوقتي زعلان مش مكتئب
ثالث حاجه
عن مشاعرك بالطريقه اللي بتشوفها مناسبه
يعني ايه انا دلوقتي لما بتعب انا شايفه
ان انا بنعدل على الناس بقفل السوشيال
ميديا ما بحبش اي حد يعرف عني اي حاجه
وبرجع كويس
شوف الطريقه اللي تريحك واعملها يعني ما
حدش يقول لك اصلا اعمل ايه ما تسمعش كلام
حد انت شوف ايه الحاجه اللي بتحرقها او
الحاجه اللي بتساعدك انك تتخلص من الموت
ده لما بفرح مثلا
بكافق نفسي بخرج خروجه بجيب حاجه بحبها
لما بخاف باكل لبان مثلا عشان بالنسبه
يعني
فشوف الطريقه اللي هتساعدك واختارها
رابع حاجه هنا بقى الاساس
هقول لكم حاجه ممكن تكون يعني هتشوفوها
متشابه بجد هي تكنيك حلو جدا جدا تقدروا
تمشيه اديكم مثال بسيط النهارده الاتنين
عامل ايه امتحان يوم الجمعه
قدامي قد ايه قدامي اربع خمس ايام هعمل
مستحيل عشان اخلص هل انت هتذاكر يوم
الجمعه خلاص
بمعنى ايه دلوقتي انا زعلانه على حاجه
معينه كل حاجه دي ايه طبعا حاجه بسيطه
برضه اي حاجه ماديه يا جماعه حاجه بسيطه
انا قدامي دلوقتي يومين ثلاثه اطلع فيهم
كل طاقه الزعل اللي عندي خلاص انا حافظ
نفسي عارف جدول المذاكره ما بيعملوش هنمشي
هنمشي بالمره العصر
يا جماعه
ولا شغلك هيستناك ولا مذاكرتك هتستناك حط
لنفسك فعلا طريقه ان انا كمان يومين ثلاثه
هتعبها من الموضوع ده
طلع كل كل طاقه الزعل اللي عندي في اي
حاجه انا بحبها او بالدكتور هي اللي انا
شايفها مناسبه
لما تحطي الكرسي مشاعرك
الدنيا بتزبط معك جامد
طيب اخر حاجه
هل انت لو حتى برج السوشيال ميديا سكريات
مثلا هاجي تاني يوم على طول اخد منها
الموبايل
كل حاجه بتيجي ما تستعجلش يعني ما تقولش
على الخطوات
نفسك على مشاعرك
بمعنى ايه
على السوشيال ميديا مثلا النهارده الوطن
بيقعد 10 ساعات على الموبايل بكره ساعات
اليوم اللي بعده
ما تفاجئش نفسك بتصدقهاش من الاخر يعني
طيب يا جماعه حياتنا كلها رحله فعلا هي
رحله والهدف منها انك تستمتع بيها
طيب في كم
او يعني كم درس ممكن اقوله لكم تستفيدوا
بيه يعني تتعاملوا بيه حياتكم تاخذوا درس
من كل حاجه في حياتكم مفيش حاجه بتحصل صد
فه اي حاجه بتقولوا فيها اي محل
يعني حاولوا تسبحوا نفسكم زي ما قلت شويه
بلاش
انت ما بتظلمش حد في الموضوع ده كله غيرك
طيب الحاجه الاهم في كل ده واللي هي حرفيا
كده انت وصلت لاعلى مراحل السلام النفسي
واتعافيت من كل حاجه كانت بتمر بها وحشه
بصراحه انا كروان يعني بقالي كتير بحاول
في الموضوع ده بس ما وصلتش لمرحله
المسامحه خالص سواء اشخاص او حاجات بمعنى
ايه
الشخص اللي اذاك انت اعلى مراحل الكلام
لنفسك انا اتخضيت خلاص انا يعني اتعافيت
من الموضوع ده هو ده بالظبط
لما بتسامح الحاجه
ممكن تكون حاجه طيب زي ايه انت خايفه مثلا
وظيفه قدمت فيها مره اثنين وثلاثه مع انك
حد كويس جدا واشتغلت في اماكن تانيه بس
عايزاك تتخيل انك مريت من قدام الوظيفه دي
بالعربيه وانت ماشي احساسك هيكون ايه
مش طايق المكان باللي فيه ولو فيه حد
عارفاه اتقبل في الوظيفه هيكون احس
اسك لان المشاعر دي مش حابه ان انا
عاملينها بس زعلان ان هو طب ليه يا رب ليش
يا رب ليش من الاخر طيب لما توصل المسامحه
هتقول خلاص ربنا عوضني خير اكيد الموضوع
ده مش خير ليه
استنى انه لا انا سامحت الحاجه دي خلاص ما
عنديش اي مشاعر وحشه
فعلا تخيل حد بيعمل انا افتكر موقف تافه
جدا يعني كلكم
الخاتم بتاعي ضاع
انا قعدت يومين ثلاثه انا دخلت نفسي
مكتئب طب ليه طبعا
انا مش عارفه احط كنت نفسي كده مش عارفه
احافظ على حاجه احافظ على حاجات
دي حاجه فعلا تستاهل تخيلوا حاجه ماديه
اشتريت غيرها مره واثنين وثلاثه واربعه
بالشكل ده الشخص اللي بيلوم نفسه فعلا
فعلا نهايته مش بتكون احسن حاجه بياذي
نفسه جدا
الانسان هو مش بيكون عمره عمره في اتجاه
جرب تاذيه كل حاجه هتكون عايزه منك انك
تبعد عمره
[موسيقى]
فعلا يعني مش نفسكم كده الحساب من حقه ان
هو يتغير بياخد خطوه تجاه نفسه ويكون احسن
ما تقتنعش
ان انت فعلا فعلا مفيش حد
من الخطا نعتذر قمه النفسي فعلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]